مع اقتراب ذكرى مرور عام على اندلاع الحرب
في اوكرانيا ما زالت ازمه الطاقات تهدد
اقتصادات الدول الاوروبيه فرنسا مثلا سجلت
عام 2022 عجزا كبيرا على خلفيه ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه جراء هذه الحرب والذي تزامن
ايضا مع نقص انتاجيه المحطات النوويه
السليمه لتصبح باريس مجبره على استيراد
الطاقه وباسعار مضاعفه
في منطقه الاعمال والمال ديفونس يستشعر
الرجال الاعمال هنا تداعيات حرب اوكرانيا
التي متعام عليها لكنها ما زالت تتصدر
المشهد الاقتصادي في فرنسا فالعجز التجاري
تضاعف العام الماضي وبلغ 164 مليار يورو
هناك مصانع اغلقت واخرى علقت اعمالها فيما
تراجع اخبار الشركات على الاستثمار هذا
العام صدمه الطاقه كلفت الدوله الفرنسيه
84 مليار يورو مقسمه تقريبا 52% على
الدوله الفرنسيه نتيجه سياسيه الدعم اللي
اعطتنا الاسر والشركات 42% تحملها الشركات
كفتره اولى وبعدين تحولت هذه التكاليف
بزياده بالاسعار على المستهلكين و6% عمليا
هي تكاليف تحملتها الاسر خلال الفتره
الماضيه اصبح المواطن الف مضطرا لتغيير
نمط استهلاكه اليومي ليتماشى مع حجم
التضخم بعدما انخفضت قدرته الشرائيه
اصبح التسوق لتامين المواد الاساسيه اكثر
تكلفه من السابق مقارنه بما تبقى من
تكاليف
عموما احاول توفير استهلاكه الطاقه في
المنزل
اذهب الى العمل بالدراجه عوضا عن السياره
ولحمايه المستهلكين من ارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه خصصت الحكومه هذا العام 45 مليار
يورو على ان تستفيد منها الاسر بشكل خاص
وبالاخص من بينها الاسر ذات الدخل المحدود
زين عدي العربيه باريس